investigators in Dallas are on the scene
of a deadly crane accident that
triggered frantic rescue efforts at
least one person was killed after the
massive crane slammed into buildings
during a powerful storm yesterday but
the AVL eyal is near the scene in Dallas
Maria what are we learning about what
happened exactly
well good morning Anthony right now fire
investigators are telling us the crane
that was involved in this accident was
actually being used at a construction
site at an apartment complex across the
street in addition to the one woman who
died inside the building of five others
were injured two of them critically it
took just seconds for this construction
crane in downtown Dallas to collapse as
winds as high as 80 miles per hour
swept through North Texas the twisted
metal sliced through this five-story
apartment complex and tore through a
neighboring parking garage David Mendoza
rushed to help an injured driver we look
over to the right and we see a gentleman
kind of dangling in his car that's like
facing straight down cars were stacked
on top of each other in the rubble below
dozens of emergency workers responded to
the scene looking for people trapped we
can't confirm the exact cause of the
collapse but you know everyone's aware
of the fact that the storm did rolled
through tower cranes like the one that
crashed can rise hundreds of feet in the
air and are often designed to withstand
hurricane-force winds of more than a
hundred miles per hour Dallas wasn't the
only area hit by Sunday's violent
weather storms moved quickly across the
region uprooting hundreds of trees
flooding roads and leaving more than
300,000 customers without power
Texas leads the country right now in
crane involved accidents where someone
died and since 2012 there have been nine
deaths but this is the first time or a
person that was not working for a
construction company was
actually killed now the construction
company that is in charge of the crane
that you see behind me they tell us that
they will be fully working with
investigators on this accident to figure
out what happened
years have a lot of questions those are
the people there thank you very much
Maria